Nâng lần đi, Chris Wright, Biltin Bo, Washington, Hông Nhã Múc Thio và Cơ sở hạ tăng nâng lượng của Yveshan,
Chúng ta cũng sức đầu tại Trung Đông tiếp tục lâu thân.
Cả quán Wright, các cuộc không tích nhan và cơ sở dấu mỏ của Yveshan chức đó là gió Isreal Tien Hành.
Chức đó các người mùi bài tháng ba ice rail được cho là đã tấn công quảng 3 mươi cơ sở dấu mỏ tại Thé Hveshan,
và các cuộc vực lớn cảnh gây xanh nhiều vụ hảo hoặc lớn.
Tây đường xanh là những cuộc tấn công đầu tiên nhằm vào một Thio thôi lĩnh vực nâng lượng của Yveshan.
Cảy thư kí chính xí của sự bắt đầu.
Khà một số ngon tên Isreal đã thông báo chức cho cuộc đổni và kế hoặc tấn công này.
Tuy nhiên các quán chức nghĩ cho biết Washington bị bất ngờ trước khi mô lớm của chính xec,
bá lóng ai vì tấn công cơ sở hạ tăng của Thé Hê tất cả đồng tư cửa tỷ tìm chương năng lượng thân cầu.
Phà nước lại của tấn công Yveshan linh tiến khẳng định sẽ đáp trả thích đáng,
tất quan thung tấn và đăng cho biết ngày 1 chiến thông bà.
Mùi bộ tấn công của Yveshan nhằm vào cơ sở lập dầu, am, mà, mì, Lê dài trảy lượng và thị thải vị thái sản.
Quán chính thêm ra gầm Mỹ đều chứa sản, vì nhá mục tiêu vòng ngày ngân lượng của Thé làm giám đoạn gồn công,
bà kiến xa sở tổng tổ tăng mạnh, chứ bố cảnh bướng vận tài của Yveshan bố đang chục nhiều xứa.